Naruto is one of the biggest anime
franchises in the world in other news
the sky is blue but one of the latest
games in the Naruto universe is finally
coming West I'm Tony and this is your
gamespot news update Naruto online is an
MMORPG from Oasis games and it's finally
coming to western territories the game
follows the events of the manga and
anime including all nine story arcs you
can play as one of five new characters
representing the elements of earth water
fire wind or lightning you'll run into
plenty of classic characters from the
show all voiced by their original actors
and iconic locations like the valley of
the end can be fully explored when it
comes to combat the game offers
turn-based battles and the ability to
recruit classic characters to your team
Naruto fans should be pleased Naruto
online will be playable on Wednesday
July twentieth you can sign up right now
through the official website the game is
officially licensed from bandai namco
and it definitely won't be the last
Naruto game they put out if you want to
keep up with all the ninjutsu you're
already in the right place